>> Now, in the process of needing to fill our canvas tiles, the method of
drawing is a little bit different than what we were doing before. Previously,
we're actually just taking a view rect and actually filling the data in. But
now, what we need to do is actually take that same logic, which we've actually
re-factored for you here. And instead of drawing it based upon the view rect, we
need to modify it to render tiles into the CanvasTile boundaries that are being
passed into the function. This works that once each of your CanvasTiles have
been created, you can actually pass it off to the fillCanvasTile function,
giving it the newly created CanvasTile. Now, the code that we've provided here
is essentially the same as our previous draw code, just refactored. The primary
difference is that our fillCanvasTile code should now take a CanvasTile, as a
parameter, and then draw to that CanvasTile's context. Using its bounding
information, rather than our primary canvas context.